[Music]
what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich for us
trying to get our lunch money right
we're going right to the whole deal
block fire is now the sponsor of lunch
money go get a blackfy account you can
go to blackfy.com
where you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest bearing
account you can buy and sell
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin or bitcoin
at blockfi or you can deposit bitcoin
you can take out a us dollar loan to get
your bitcoin collateral
go to block fi they're awesome they're
the best i'm an investor i sit on the
board and basically i think that
you'll be awesome if you go when you get
a black fighter i can't go to block
fight.com
what's up paulina well this morning
anthony's been
screaming dancing making weird noises
all morning because bitcoin hit an
all-time high
at 44 000 which yeah
that's that's an all-time high i don't
care about the price
well what do you care about oh the the
price the price doesn't matter to me
it's what drives the price that matters
right
the price going up of course it's going
to go up it's a fix supply asset demand
is increasing
i always ask people do you think in 10
years more people are going to want
bitcoin or less people
if you think more people are going to
want bitcoin then bitcoins us dollar
price will be
higher if you think less people are
going to want bitcoin
it'll be lower that
my ladies and gentlemen friends is a
economics 101 course in supply
and demand unless you think that we have
violated supply and demand
frameworks then the bitcoin price has to
go up over time as demand increases
that's how supply and demand works
um which leads us to our next topic
which is also bitcoin
tesla bought 1.5 billion dollars in
bitcoin and plans to accept it
as payment i told y'all i told you
i told you this was going to happen
everyone was laughing
tesla's not going to do it the 4500
companies are going to do you know what
most people are going to do just like
bitcoin
shut up i told you all that [ __ ] was
going to happen
do not tell my friends to shut up no no
no the people here they believe they
watch every day
i'm saying the bears the losers the
pessimists of the world
they didn't believe and i told you it
was gonna happen
why because every corporation
in the world is going to put bitcoin on
their balance sheet
do we think that tesla doing this is now
gonna
push all the other fortune 500 companies
over the edge
i think that this drastically reduced
the career risk for a cfo why
if elon musk and tesla one of the the
richest man in the world and one of the
most valuable companies
a little wacky right are other are other
ceos gonna be just as wacky they're like
oh you know is jack dorsey wacky
they're all wacky compared to the really
like
um what did you call them buttoned up
like
oh the nerds ceos of the fortune 500
companies are they going to name a ceo
you think is not wacky
okay like whoever the ceo of uh
um what is that called just give me a
big company like like
walmart oh walmart yeah they seem to be
doing great against amazon
oh ford they seem to be doing great
against tesla
maybe they should get wacky ceos then so
that they can actually be innovative
embrace technology
and apple have you tried to use
an apple product lately okay your apple
product is right here right there yeah
oh i use that don't worry
but i'm just saying that apple is now
trying to build a car they're gonna go
try to compete with elon
elon is two steps ahead he's playing
checkers while you idiots are playing
chess so the lesson here is be wacky but
speaking of wacky
speaking of wacky wacky sometimes why
is was elon talking about dogecoin
yesterday
i personally believe that elon is one
hilarious too is that he
he was prepping everyone right he he was
kind of
uh desensitizing people to him talking
about crypto him talking about all this
yeah but why wouldn't he be talking
about bitcoin to desensitize them why
would he be talking about it
about dogecoin why would he talk about
bitcoin it's in the price
before he bought it oh does he own
douchecoin
uh my guess is that he does not own any
dogecoin
because the fact that he's tweeting
about it he knows it's uh
impacting the price if he was buying it
and then selling it and stuff that would
be pretty bad
but you know who's funny who snoop doge
okay do you want to know my favorite
elon tweet what
who let the doge out
anyway um let's not talk about doge
let's talk about goats
tom tams almost call him tim brady oh my
god tim cook
tim okay tim out
tom brady uh just won his seventh super
bowl
with the tampa not tompa which i
recently learned bay buccaneers
not buccaneers um he'd be
they'd be they beat the kansas city
chiefs 31-9
in brady's 10th super bowl
i mean if he's not a go i'm a sheep
that didn't make any sense uh listen
he's very very very very very
good i just don't think it can be the
greatest of all time if you can't beat
eli eli manning and tom brady met twice
in the super bowl and tom brady is
oh for two okay why has eli manning not
gone to 10 super bowls if he's so good
because he didn't need to he's efficient
he goes to super bowl he wins that's it
he he's great when you go to the super
bowl you win
tom brady won seven times tom brady has
lost more super bowls then eli manning
has won i i can't think about that for a
second that's how many super bowls tom
brady has lost
tom brady has lost more super bowls
than eli manning only three okay that's
a lot
he's won seven thirty percent of the
time he goes to the super bowl and he
loses
a hundred percent of the time eli
manning goes to super bowl and he wins
yeah cause a shot he only went he was
lucky to be there those two times anyway
all right um next topic tom brady is
amazing
obviously you have to respect the
greatness uh i recently wrote about him
in the profile the profile.subsec.com
tom brady okay um clubhouse
is now blocked in china after a brief
uncensored period clubhouse
sorry the yawn that it just i just it
happened
remember when you're like stop yeah well
i'm trying to fight it and then i just
let that one take over my body i was
like just just take me wherever you want
to go
so audio drop in startup clubhouse was
rapidly gaining steam in china
until the chinese government decided to
censor it
you lucky you live in america in terms
of freedom of speech
communists suck all right is that all
you have to say
it's just look i'm a fan of free speech
i'm a fan of free
uh of democracy i'm a fan of capitalism
i think essentially planned economy
doesn't make a lot of sense and i think
that the lack of free speech
means that they're scared of something
and if their citizens want to talk to
each other let them talk
what are they scared of the people
the people rising up and saying this is
garbage we don't want to deal with this
anymore hey little kids sitting at home
listen pay attention this is a kids show
this is important very very important
the chinese way of doing things
we don't do that in america that's not
how it's supposed to work
you are a free person you have personal
freedoms you have individual liberties
in your life you must stand up for the
right thing
when those things are infringed on and
so when you see things like this you
should
step up and you should say hey this is
not right they should not do that they
should allow
people to have free speech if you don't
know what free speech is because you're
too little
ask your mom or your dad to explain it
to you and if they say
i don't know tell them yes you do
explain it to me
wow okay and then ask them for ice cream
no people i'm sorry parents
y'all better start teaching about free
speech or we're going to do ice cream
days
it's ask lunch money time ask lm
in the comments below your questions
don't just have to be about bitcoin and
the blockchain your questions could be
you know about the profile or what i'm
eating for lunch today
okay peter lopez hi guys great show
thank you for all you do
what are your thoughts if another
country are you listening yeah i'm
listening
another country other than the usa jumps
ahead with bitcoin such
cryptocurrency as part of their budget
leading the market or the world is
waiting for the states to be the leader
in bitcoin since the world's principal
reserve currency
is in the us dollar thank you for your
time to educate us what do you think
i actually think that other countries
will adopt it anyway
even if the u.s does not so it's in the
us's benefit
to adopt it you are very smart that is
why you are my wife because you are so
intelligent
what do you have to say i agree no
another country is going to adopt it
before the united states
obviously the u.s come on the u.s has
the mentality we don't need to be first
we just need to make sure that we last
um thank you satoshi asks
do you think
okay thank you satoshi asks do you think
institutions concentrate the ownership
of
bitcoin what does that mean for us
little guys how does that impact its
network effect
oh good day to ask this song listen
let me tell you guys something what you
need to do is you just crashed your neck
you need to get your bitcoin
you need to wrap your little hands are
on that bitcoin
you need to hold that bitcoin for dear
life
up down sideways backwards
green men falling from the sky whatever
happens
just wrap your hands around that bitcoin
and hold on to it for dear life
don't sell it to one of the institutions
don't sell it
to your neighbor don't sell it to a
corporation
it's your bitcoin there are many like it
but this one is yours
okay so hold that bitcoin as tightly as
you can
is that a lion king reference no what
was that
uh jar head there are many rifles
like this but this one is mine i said it
was a lion king well
many kingdoms like it but this one is
there's only one king there's only one
kingdom and satoshi is king
hold that queen hold that bitcoin
and don't let anybody take it from you
don't let anybody shake you out of it
just hold the bitcoin and the bitcoin
will take you to the promised land
because it is the hardest sound this
money the world has ever seen and it is
digitally provable and it's auditable
and it is going to eat the world i have
a question
yes what if um what if
in like 10 years oh my god what if in
like 10 years
it comes out that i am actually satoshi
what would you do like how would you
react to that piece of information
uh i think on one of the lunch money
episodes you said there was 30 million
bitcoins no it's 21 million
yeah no no no maybe i was doing it to
take you off the track
oh you were trying to throw me off the
scent yeah
okay right but like how would you react
how does it how does a blockchain work
it chains blocks in um every few minutes
and how many minutes transactions um
eight
nine three
10 10 i knew it see just trying to
trying to keep you on your toes you
think i don't know and then
when there's what's the difference
between a bitcoin with a capital b and a
lowercase b
there is none false it's
there's no wait you ask me yes no there
is what is it capital b
refers to the payment rail and lowercase
b refers to the asset
really yes okay give me another one
where was
uh satoshi when he created bitcoin where
on the internet
kind of but no geographically
uh texas wait really
north america japan
how do you know where he was nobody
knows i just said that
no you didn't i said give me a non-trick
question a non-trick question
the internet was the right answer how
many bitcoin are coming into the
circulating supply on a daily basis
right now
oh so 20 like
less than a bitcoin what
900. you are so close
all right what's next that's it that's
it all right guys that's it for lunch
money
bitcoin hold it tight this is not
financial advice do your own research
but what i am telling you is the dollars
guaranteed to lose value bitcoin is
guaranteed to go up as long as demand
continues to increase
and therefore you me her and everybody
else who understands bitcoin who
realizes that
bitcoin is the soundest hardest money in
the world and
is digitally protected by proof of work
and the strongest computing network in
the world
will likely be pretty good and the best
part
to end the episode on is the world's
richest
man agrees save your satoshi's
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends